all right joining me now the man of the
hour virginia republican gubernatorial
candidate glenn younkin who has some
supporters behind him don't ask me how i
know uh glenn i expect your day on fox
and friends and now you're entering in
on prime time i know you're going to
continue afterwards but as we look at
the return so far uh 12
of the statewide registered voters have
voted already what does that mean to you
and your chances of beating terry
mcauliffe well first of all there's no
enthusiasm for terry mcauliffe no one's
showing up to vote and it just
translates in the fact that he's invited
anybody who's ever held office anywhere
in america in a democrat seat is to come
campaign with him but what we're seeing
is big enthusiasm on our side and this
is what's happening across virginia this
is no longer republicans against
democrats it's virginians coming
together to make a statement that
they're ready to elect a different kind
of governor a governor and get things
done as opposed to one who's just full
of empty promises and by the way a tired
43-year career i know you know numbers
that got you into politics you had your
success in numbers so i don't you can't
see it right now but we're going to put
up a map now of the 2017 governor's race
and it's mostly red but the blue areas
of the most dense areas ed gillespie
lost to ralph northam in 2020 on the
other side you see donald trump lost by
10 points to joe biden it's only been a
few months since that election nine
months in all how do you plan on going
to those highly populated areas those
blue areas and doing something that
neither one of those republicans are
able to do and that's when what is your
message going to resonate in those areas
well we're bringing people together as i
said what we're seeing of course in the
most recent polling is it's not that
we've caught up we're actually moving
past terry mcauliffe and that is because
we're doing great in the in the
traditional red areas and we are doing
really well in those blue cities we in
fact are seeing great support in loudoun
county in fairfax county we're seeing
great support all through hampton roads
and we're seeing great support all
through the greater richmond area it's
been super and the biggest issues the
biggest issues is education we're
actually seeing parents stand up and say
hey listen i actually have a big say
about my kids education and terry
mcauliffe wants to put government
between parents and their children and
virginia parents are saying no not here
and i'm going to go to work for virginia
parents and terry mcauliffe stands for
government right and virginians are
voting right now to make sure that they
have a say in their kids
obviously a lot of enthusiasm so i'm
looking at loudoun county and i haven't
memorized all the districts like bill
hammer in virginia but louden was won
by joe biden by 20 points fairfax by 40
and prince william by 30. as you look at
those numbers you wonder how much
education has to do with your chances in
the long run because louden county seems
to be the most upset by the curriculum
they're forced to digest including what
we're just finding out now about this
second step program that you need to
sign an nda in order to look at if
you're a parent what is this done to
your chances what have you found out
well of course i called for a full
investigation of the loudoun county
school board these the loudoun county
school superintendent and the
commonwealth attorney because they're
not standing up for children's safety
they're not even standing up to get the
schools open they're not standing up for
curriculum they're not standing up for
materials that are being shown to kids
that parents don't want to see anymore
they won't even stand up for their
safety and this is actually turning
loudoun county our direction but not
just louden county all of northern
virginia you watch we're going to do
better in northern virginia than any
republican has done in a long time and
we just might win loudoun county
that that would probably deliver the
state because if you can make up a
20-point gap glenn i'm getting a lot of
reports that you have only one vest can
you confirm or deny that
i have i have multiple vests but i'm
telling you this is my lucky one you
know
you know you may have you may have seen
me bury a three-pointer on on the other
night and challenge uh barack obama in a
game on one-on-one and he hasn't taken
me up yet but i'm telling you i'm ready
and this vest is going to take me home
we're going to win on november 2nd and
folks i can't wait to be the next
governor of virginia well
i don't know what you're on it looks
like day one of the campaign instead of
the back stretch it's seven days away
glenn younkin thanks for starting your
day and ending your day with me i
appreciate it
thank you very very much have a great
time here we go folks thank you